[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
oh
[Music]
drop a [ __ ]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
swinging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yay
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
oh
[Music]
now
[Music]
yo check this out
[Music]
my
this great
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
don't check this out
[Music]
so
[Music]
chocolate
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to id at xbox showcase i am
megan camarena also known as
strawberry17 plays on twitch what's up
hi and i'm steve saylor aka blind gamer
steve here on twitch welcome everyone
welcome chat i see a few people in here
i see panda ninja one three four five
legend of the cabela of the baby uh and
bellion solo thank you so much all for
tuning in today i am really really
excited because today we're talking
indies at xbox megan
how how like a type level from one to
ten how are you
i'm over nine thousand okay steve indie
games are just like my favorite thing in
the entire world it's like someone had a
crazy idea and they're like let's turn
it into a video game and that's what
makes my heart soar truly truly i love
that because because i'm going to need
your help because of course like i i'm
more of the aaa side i i play some
indies here and there um but i like i
come from from that side i think so i
want to be able to like could you be my
guide my coach could you be my coach ted
lasso today for all of indy's
better yet i'm going to be your uncle
iro okay there we go
and i'm gonna show you the light the
greener patches of indie gaming and it's
just gonna be
it's gonna be a spiritual experience
okay so heat up that tee we're about to
jump right in
yes awesome i'll have to grab some tea
later um so for chat for those who are
watching just to kind of like set things
up here's what's gonna happen today
we're basically gonna be about two hours
of a ton of different stuff and no i
wish believe me i wish i could be able
to say what the release date is for halo
infinite but that is not the goal for
today today is all about indies uh we
have so much stuff playing for you halo
can sit down for a second okay it's the
indies gamed time to shine master chief
sit back
he can wait he can chill for a bit it's
okay he's he's got all winter he's got a
20th anniversary waiting for him exactly
yeah so on today's show we'll be
showcasing and celebrating in the xbox
games and we'll have many talented devs
joining us throughout the day to talk
about their games including eon drive
the veil shadow of the crown stardew
valley yes we have an announcement for
stardew valley and space lines from the
far out and we'll also be joined by
guest streamers for some fun interviews
and actual live gameplay demos of some
of the games we're gonna be talking
about today including we're gonna have
some streamers that that bronze girl
ocadrian and snow lit
we'll also have an exclusive interview
with sarah bond head of game creator
experience at microsoft and throughout
the day we'll be dropping exclusive new
game trailers and let you know what
games are coming to game pass so this is
a first look no one's seen this before
i've never before seen ever and i love
it i love it i'm gonna have a hard time
containing myself because like at like
e3 whenever uh an annapurna uh
like a logo comes up i'm the one that's
screaming in the crowd so if that
happens today i might not be able to
contain myself i'm just letting you know
i think you're really hyped for indie
games
that i i can't wait i can't wait to be
able to like be here with that reaction
uh with you and also speaking of you
chat you're going to be a big part of
today's show didn't i know you didn't
sign up like may not sign up for this
but this is your job for today i always
say yeah sure come on
exactly make sure to take part using the
chat we'll be sending your thoughts your
questions and we'll call you out all
throughout the day uh and i am just yeah
i'm really really excited so chad come
on join in
yeah yeah and as a reminder chat all
twitch gaming shows are co-streamable so
join in on the fun and co-stream our
shows because why not
exactly and i've i can attest i've been
a co-streamer for this uh so this is
great and it's also dmca free which is a
ton of fun
love that
uh all right and so throughout uh
throughout today's we're gonna be
showing a bunch of different stuff and
never before seen trailers so make sure
to share your reactions here in twitch
chat so let's get right into it first up
we are dropping some new game trailers
let's take a look
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
driven from our homes by the toxic
spores we kept wandering looking for
shelter
but not in our wildest dreams did we
imagine what we would find
[Music]
after all this time we were given an
opportunity
[Music]
together we will cross this vast poison
wasteland
[Music]
in search of a place yet untainted
[Music]
using everything we can find
to build a society that can protect and
provide for all of us
human
and animal alike
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello tester
[Music]
i am sarah my algorithms suggest you
might enjoy wanton life solving puzzles
[Music]
do you feel more engaged knowing that
you are being evaluated by your
community
good i will now gauge your interest in
multiplayer
i am helping we are doing this together
as we are bonding as people bond by
doing action
do not panic all of my systems are
normal two hundred percent normal
three thousand percent normal
completely normal
[Music]
wow
wait where do we start there's a robots
that farm and then there's like uh
another like a farming simulator
basically
oh my gosh on the back of a turtle
oh my gosh we're just talking about
avatar the last airbender that just gave
me like that those kind of vibes
oh my gosh did it say game freak did i
see that
i i think yeah i think it did for her
for light year frontier
that one looks cool so legit i like like
i love
okay i mean i'm gonna go back to as far
as firefly i love any kind of space show
that has a bunch of like kind of country
sort of guitar to it soundtrack that
just warms the cockles of my heart
that goggles off your heart i'm so i'm
like i love these type of games because
speaking of stardew valley like roller
coaster tycoon uh i i also play like a
lot of app games like mini motorways or
outlanders and it's all about kind of
setting up your
your town and your community and
watching it thrive and uh
the first and second game both looked
like a lot of that
oh so they're actually those so this is
a sequel then
yeah oh is it
i don't know i'm just
i'm here this you're the guide oh that's
okay
this is like this is i'm just saying
these are the types of games i love to
play these are types of games okay
gotcha gotcha okay yeah because that's
what it's like
no no no it's fine it looks like it's
kind of like a no man's sky but like
maybe a little bit of like like
multiplayer kind of thing or cold at
least so that looks really really cool
now tell me about wandering village here
what are your excitement levels for this
oh
it looks like so i love the little like
story in the beginning it kind of like
made my heart a little tender uh chat
says they're they're they're stoked to
play it looks super cute um i love the
artwork this is this is such a beautiful
looking game already from the start and
i wonder what's the story what's the
world that we're living in um and how do
we like progress throughout the game i i
imagine you just
you
imagine you could like
was like what did you advance in
civilization do you start having
skyscrapers like what's interesting what
happens
you know oh my gosh yeah like
that would be interesting too because
i'm like i'm thinking i'm like because
it looks like it like it is a bit of
kind of like it has a like to me it has
like a stardew valley kind of vibe which
is yeah which already like i was kind of
set like i was already interested a
little bit and started you haven't
played it yet but i'm like this is kind
of like a cool thing i don't know it's
it's the it's the island on the turtle's
back
that's just still kind of like i don't
know why that's messing with my head but
i'm like i i think that that's just so
interesting and so cool i kind of want
to like can i i kind of want to play
this now i i kind of want to i can't
wait
i know this is so cool they got
flamethrowers look at that flamethrower
what's happening there how do you oh my
gosh
i'm kind of wondering that too because
now it looks like okay so that looks
like a skeleton of an old turtle does
that mean we get to find like other
people's turtles and other people's like
villages oh my gosh and what if you
could like trade resources or something
like that
what are there zombie people on the dead
dinosaurs zombies oh my gosh okay okay i
am
now that's cool now let's talk about lab
rat here uh
i'm getting portal vibes from this like
1 000 right yeah it looks like a little
bit of a puzzler
messed me up a tiny bit this ai system i
was like wait what
exactly yeah it's like sort of like it
makes it seem like kind of like a glado
sort of like
like they seem nice it seems nice but
then it's just like you know
chat you know you know ai is just never
always our friend in games and
uh it looks like that even though
everything is fine
quote unquote uh i'm like i'm i'm
already like scared of what that ai can
do to me i don't like sarah sarah come
on
i mean it looks like you need a big
brain for that last game so i mean
that's that's a great i like to play the
big game uh big brain games with my
twitch chat because it's i know it's a
little bit cheaty but i'll sit there and
be like hmm i'm not pretty sure what to
do and then there's always that one
smart person in chat that's like up down
left right and then turn around and then
and then it's done and then i'm like
wait i think i got it i think i have
this and then
i like plus two i like actually
in the chat like lab rat pits you
against everyone else who plays the game
i wonder if that's true
cause that'd be dope
oh my gosh like kind of like a ghost
system of being like okay well how did
everyone else sort of do and like oh
that be oh now now the brain's firing
now i'm like okay i kind of want to see
what more about this game i want to know
more about it this is oh my gosh i'm
excited
me too
well uh i guess we're going to intro the
next trailer
um we have more trailer reveals for you
right now next up
new gameplay and new feature trailers
let's take a hot look yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
hi there i'm simon bennett from award
winning studio roll seven and this is
our new game olly ollyworld
it's a bold new action platformer that's
bursting with personality with a cartoon
inspired art style
approachable yet deep mechanics
and a slick soundtrack to boom
but who are you in all of this
well we're excited to reveal today that
you can be whoever you want to be
for the first time in the series you can
fully customize your character from your
body type and skin tone to your dress
sense and skateboard
you have full control
so you can choose the vibe that suits
you
but of course it's more than just
picking the right moustache
from drake's functional workwear to the
eco-friendly gear from twiggy's as well
as tired-eye stone threads from face
melter there are hundreds of different
clothing items to choose from
unlock and combine as you explore
ollyoli world
want to skate in your flip-flops we've
got you covered want to wear a bumblebee
onesie all right no worries in all the
early world as long as you're on a board
anything goes
but that's not all
we're also giving you the ability to
shape how you skate and the kind of
style you have
go retro with loads of old-school grabs
play it steezy with a running start or
take the high road with your rival pose
all of this combines to allow you to
really make your character your own
and stand out in the community challenge
modes with your own personality
and finally i'm excited to announce that
if you play olly ollie world on xbox
series consoles then you'll be able to
experience the sublime flow state
gameplay in up to super smooth 120
frames a second and beautiful 4k
resolution
oleoli world also supports smart
delivery and is coming to xbox series x
and s and xbox one this winter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
my
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
quit moving around so much bobblehead
when are we gonna get another case sam
okay don't scream this time
sam and max reporting for duty you said
duty
we're after the most infamous crime
outfit in the city where do we start sam
no idea let's go
when you love what you do it doesn't
even feel like work
we've got to stop that bean from
hypnotizing anyone else pretty sharp
mcgruff don't call me that
shouldn't we revel a little our journey
to the dark side has just begun
wait available today sam and max
remastered wait
what
oh my god oh
inked comes out on the 27th which is
like not too far away if i can imagine
yeah oh wow okay okay all right first
off okay
max i remember playing that as a kid
you reverse back reverse so sam and max
save the world remastered i
the fact that it's available today okay
i'm excited i'm like i think i'm gonna i
i i'm not gonna lie sorry sorry folks
the twitch game i'm gonna go download it
right now
playing it right now in the background
yeah like peace out i'm out
okay well that's rpg time the very first
time have you ever played uh lost worlds
beyond the page
no i haven't it's an any game where
basically as you play the game a journal
kind of fills up and uh things you like
draw you create the drawings or the
words and i i love those type of games
they're like my favorite and the legend
of right kind of it looks like that
right
uh where
at first it's giving me super mario
vibes um but i i love this journal esque
gameplay where things get colored in and
reveal themselves as you start playing
and exploring more of the page it's so
pretty and the art style is just
fantastic
yeah oh that looks that looks really
really cool and i mean i'm always on the
lookout for a new sort of like rpg to
kind of sink i like my time into and
this
this kind of has like a cool like if i
was bored in in school at sitting at my
desk and i was just sort of like just
doodling in my in my notepad uh like
that this is the kind of thing that i
just sort of would would imagine uh like
myself doing like just just coming up
with this sort of crazy world that holy
cow this spread like this is huge this
looks awesome
the visuals are just so fun too i just i
love all that it reminds me of toy story
a little bit i'm not gonna lie you know
it has all these different elements
where it's like super refreshing for the
eye to see
um
it's it's it looks so fun it looks super
cute and it looks like it's going to be
a really really good time i wonder what
the story is that that kid is oh
and it's coming this winter so there we
go we're getting
some fun games like indie games are
going to play in the in the winter so i
love that um now let's talk about
ollyworld because have you have you
played ooblets
no i haven't
okay oh my goodness that's another like
really great game on xbox but uh this
game kind of reminds me of that just a
little bit but it's skateboarding and i
i love skateboarding steve i don't know
if you know this about me i've been
skating for the last 20 years so and
they had a skateboarding game
sign me up
okay because i was gonna say like this
is kind of giving me like i can't
skateboard to save my life because being
blind you know eye hand coordination
right feet coordination doesn't seem to
work out too well but i remember i do
remember playing like tony hawk and all
that back in the day so like and even i
think there was like even i playing
skate for a little bit so this kind of
gives me kind of like a nice cartoon
like 90s vibe a little bit like rocket
power casey 22 says it's ooblets meets
tony hawk
definitely oh i love that that's a yeah
yeah
um and then like then say like sam and
max too like that like remastered i'm
just like really really excited
h2 yeah yeah that's gonna make me cry
this can make me ugly crying i'm here
for it i love a good game that makes me
ugly cry all right that got creepy near
the end there i was like i was on board
it was like cool hand-drawn it's from
the artist i'm like this is gonna be a
nice kind of chill time and then all of
a sudden this hand like a hand of god
comes out of nowhere and like kidnaps
one of your friends what dude my butt
clinched okay i don't know if i could
say that but it's it all right
i get it i i i get i was i was in there
with you i was like wait what what what
okay what what's going on i need to know
now
yeah
oh my gosh that's so cool um so all
right chap
we're like and i know and i get it a lot
a lot of talking not a lot of game not a
lot of gameplay not a lot of trailers i
understand that but think of this as
also like a reveal trailer but also a
little bit of reaction streams that you
see with your friends so that's that's
kind of that's kind of what we're in for
for today um but chat
buckle up
exactly because we have an amazing
amazing amazing guest here oh yeah we're
like we're this we're we're we're
talking big time today's showcase is
focused on celebrating all the amazing
indie games coming to xbox soon and
sarah bond who is the head of creator
experience at microsoft will be joining
us in a moment to share her thoughts on
this incredible indie dev program before
we say hello
let's take a look at all the amazing
work coming from id at xbox
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Music]
you know i feel good
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining gosh
sarah hello this is awesome
hi how are you guys thanks for having me
good how are you
i am great i'm having a great summer but
i just love seeing all of those games
they just every time i see um id games
it makes me smile
me too serif okay for anyone who doesn't
know could you tell us a little bit uh
about your role at microsoft
yeah so um i lead game creator
experience at microsoft which means that
my team and i we get to manage all the
relationships we have with game
developers around the world but we also
develop the tools and services that game
creators use to make their games
it's so amazing what you guys do and i
can't tell you how much it means to me
as a gamer uh because
we're showcasing a lot of games from
developers who are publishing for their
very first time that may not have the
platform or the funding to be able to uh
see their dream come to pass and the id
xbox program
it helps accelerate that in such a
beautiful way uh what excites you most
about that fact
yeah there are so many things that i
love about id and xbox and what it
unlocks you know game
creation is extremely complex but it's
also beautiful because you get to tell a
story from a point of view
and but it can be hard it can be hard to
break into the industry and that's one
of the reasons why we created id at xbox
is to make it possible for
any dev to have an idea to create it and
bring it to xbox because that means that
we get to hear their stories and it
creates enormous opportunity for them so
that montage you just saw
you know what i loved about it is that
they look amazing but it showcases
developers from around the world
developers from different backgrounds uh
all-female led studio non-binary devs a
solo african-american developer and that
i think is incredible because those are
voices that today aren't as represented
in our industry as we would like and
they get to actually come to console for
the first time with ib at xbox
i love that because you mentioned in
regards to like diverse developers like
there's a wide variety of devs out there
from everything from aaa to indy and i
love what uh id and xbox is doing like
even from my side like i come from the
accessibility side seeing kind of what
um xbox has been able to provide
developers in regards to accessibility
guidelines and play testing and all that
stuff and it seems that um like xbox
provides a lot of resources and tools um
for developers to try to be able to make
kind of their dream game how they wanted
to so what role does id at xbox play
when supporting those independent game
creators um and get their games
published within xbox
yeah i love that you point that out so
id at xbox is this incredible program
you can if you want to make a game if
you're a game developer you aspire to
make a game all you have to do is go to
id at xbox.com the website you can
register once you're registered you get
to communicate and with our team and
when you have your game concept you
submit your game concept and when the
game concept is approved we give you the
tools that you need to make that game so
you'll get two free dev kits you get
full access to the sdk and all of the
guidelines to make your game and then at
the end of the cycle when your game is
complete and you're ready to submit you
can submit the title get it certified
and published and also continually be
able to update that title for free on
our platform so it really makes the
process of publishing a game very very
easy and self-service for all developers
globally
i love that and so like with all of the
games that we're announcing today as
well as what we what you've kind of
already previously been announced like
just even that scene that hype trailer
which is so awesome um what like for you
personally what is like id at xbox's
proudest accomplishment to date
gosh that's a hard one uh i know i know
it's hard like trying to pick your
children i know like it's really hard
and it's probably one of the parts of my
job that i love most just because of
what we get to see and all the
incredible experiences but i would just
say that um you know since i did xbox
has launched we've actually brought more
than 2 000 games to xbox and game
developers have made over two billion
dollars in revenue from the iv xbox
program and that just makes me just so
joyful because this is opportunity that
otherwise wouldn't exist for developers
they're games that get to be experienced
by players that might have never
otherwise seen the world and i just love
that part of the program and i can't
wait to see it continue
i love that and and also keeping uh kind
of expanding on that a bit like we've
seen like indies make like a huge splash
in the industry uh over the past few
years and even more so over the course
of this past year within the pandemic
when people are just trying to find
games to be able to play um so are you
surprised that the indie game space has
captured worldwide attention and also
huge fan bases
i mean honestly
not at all when i first started in this
role that was one of the things that
really attracted me to it uh there are
games and brands that we all know and
love but in the indie space you
continuously see just creations
experiences technological breakthroughs
that are at the forefront of the
industry and i love that people are
seeing that more enjoying it more it's a
part of our industry that we've been
embracing more and more and i also have
loved all that we've been able to do
with indies through game pass which has
really accelerated the ability for them
to be discovered and played globally so
for me it's something that i think is
only going to become bigger especially
as we develop more and more tools and
services that really democratize game
development and make it possible for
teams of all sizes to create their
vision fully
i think you touched on something that i
absolutely love and i know that you are
like obviously a huge fan of game pass i
am as well for accessibility purposes
because it allows us to be able to kind
of have that the day of the demos again
which is so cool you download a game try
it out if it doesn't work for you you
can delete it and try a different one
and i love that sort of like you're
using kind of like indies and uh at xbox
to kind of like really push the game
pass forward so how it like how is that
working with game pass uh with the indie
studios to try to like kind of combine
the two together kind of make like this
over like amazing experience for for
developers
yeah i mean you know developers do love
game pass it's a great service for
players like you said because you get to
try games but it's also a great service
for developers and particularly indie
developers because it drives discovery
so we see that um games that go into
game pass engagement in those games goes
up about eight times versus otherwise
and in people who subscribe to game
gamecast play about 40 percent more
games and they play way more genres
because people are willing to try
something they wouldn't as others before
and because indies by their very nature
are most often something we haven't seen
before something in creative and new
it's hugely valuable to them uh and i
think it's really changed how a lot of
us think of gaming because before you
know people might say look i'm gonna i'm
only gonna buy one or two games from a
brand i know now with game pass with a
monthly subscription you can try all of
these games and and continue to explore
and learn
uh and see things that are new and
exciting
it's also so cool the marketing behind
um
id at xbox these these indie developers
you know they they can have a really
good idea and a cool game but it could
go up on steam and no one ever gets to
play it or see it and you guys have such
a great platform to be able to showcase
and
sell the game to people who might not
normally play it um that's been my
favorite thing i love going through and
watching the trailer i love uh the
showcase the showcases that they're just
like kind of my absolute favorite thing
so my final my final question for you is
how do developers get involved at id at
xbox how do they make their their dream
game come true and how do you guys help
them
look i just reach out it seems amazing
but it's that simple but if you go to
ideatexbox.com
you register you get to talk to our team
we'll lean in and help you and i love
the other thing you mentioned because
the help just it starts with developing
the game but we also are really
committed to marketing our id at xbox
games we love having them in the e3
showcase we love having live streams
with them we love showcasing them on the
dash bringing them into game pass and
really enabling these developers to be
successful but the first step is easy
which is just reach out and register
with us so that we can start working
together
i love that you're making dreams come
true and i get more games to play so
thank you thank you so much sarah it's a
bit of a game
i'm thinking about it i kid you not i
was thinking about it yesterday i have a
couple games in my noggin and i'm like
hey okay
check your email okay i'm coming i'm
coming thank you so much for joining us
now
exactly yes thank you very much sarah
thank you so very much you're the
ultimate badass at xbox and i love it
they'll be able to talk to you thank you
thank you bye guys
bye
i love sarah sarah said we're friends
now basically
oh my gosh oh that doesn't i could be i
could be friends with sarah that's so
cool i i guess we're friends i said i
said i'm friend but it is like i think
it was you know there was something
there right
yeah there was something yeah i i felt
it too i felt the friendly vibes for
sure yeah yeah yeah
it's not now i just need to work on that
that email all right you know just gotta
submit that to the introductory email
yeah yeah you know have like you know
coffee with tea whatever
i like that
cool i like where this is going
exactly i like this brainstorming uh
cool well thank you so much again to
sarah for joining us today um we have
more trailer reveals for you right now
next up new game play and new features
trailers
let's take a look
yes
there's stuff happening there's stuff
happening i'll keep reacting
[Laughter]
okay you know what
take a pause we had a bit of technical
difficulties in there just just let you
know it's okay we're we're trying to be
able to get
i just disappeared oh no
it was it was it's it's a it's not even
monday it's tuesday and and my computer
just was like you know what
we're just gonna have to do it
yeah it didn't want to work well and
play with others so
you know things just don't go how
they're supposed to technology fails you
and you're just like what happens it
happens
it totally happens it's all it's all
it's all good um so instead of entry
trailers we're actually gonna like jump
into a really really cool uh gameplay
segment um so up next we have that
bronze girl is gonna be joined by
another twitch gaming regular okadrian
you've seen him here before for a live i
love him too for a live gameplay
demonstration of eon drive with the dev
team eon drive an action pl a platformer
with a speed running twist in eon drive
you can rush through cyberpunk
landscapes of neo barcelona while using
time and space spending abilities to get
ahead before we welcome the eon drive
team and our playtester ok adrian to the
id at xbox showcase let's take a look at
the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
we're through let's get to it
wait who are you
[Music]
hello i am that bronze girl and i'm here
with ocadrian we are going to be
speaking with the devs of eon drive
today how's everyone feeling
thanks
hello fantastic
hello
so
i'm sorry i think i might have a little
bit of a delay um
so we got to take a look at some of the
gameplay for eon drive um that ocadrian
was running through eon drive is set in
neo barcelona can i ask uh what the
inspiration for this location was
well that was pretty easy we most of the
team is is from barcelona from the
actual barcelona city so we wanted to
kind of
bring a
parallel version of our city and show it
to the world in a in a different light
right
fantastic um the soundtrack was also
absolutely amazing um
do you have any touchstones for what
inspired you for the music or any
artists you were excited to work with
yeah we
we've been working with
music vortex
he's a composer in the netherlands and
has created the whole soundtrack for
korean drive
it's mostly synth based
we try to go
we try to go for um this kind of
cyberpunk type of bike and
but it was at one point we decided this
ball to mix in a bit of uh rethrow music
from the 80s so pop music from the 80s
so if you pay attention to this
soundtrack you may hear some
tunes that remind you of that
we also have one special track that's
been done by
special guest
megan mcduffie where we have um boys as
well and she has she sings in the in the
sound and
yeah
let's let's read it
fantastic
um i saw that on that there's like a
discord integration and that there's the
ability to play uh co-op as well as
competitively do you mind going into
that a little bit on how that works
uh yeah once the game launch there will
be the mode to play the
campaign in co-op so you can play with
up to three friends so that would make
four of you you can play through the
story together and there will also be a
pvp mode where you can go
and race all the tracks and see see who
wins
fantastic
um
you know with games like these i find
sometimes like with side-scrolling uh
platformers they're very difficult uh it
but it seems like the protagonist
actually has some special powers at her
uh sort of uh whims to help you get
through the level do you mind going into
that a little bit about how that works
uh yeah
this is jack you can see her now she
will have her trustworthy sword to slice
some enemies along the way and her
teleportation dagger that you can use uh
we will see it now there you go she can
use it to teleport
to uh well space and time
uh all the levels feature a 30 second uh
timer but you can add time to the clock
so even though it's like focus on speed
running and beating the timer uh we also
wanted to cater for people that want a
more you know relaxed approach they want
to enjoy it to a certain extent so you
can add a little bit of time to the 30
seconds and take a little bit more to
complete each level
yeah um how does the co-op affect that
at all um do you still have 30 seconds
are there ways for you to add time to
like your team timer
uh it will work the same you can add the
time on the on the regular
mode of the game if you choose to to do
it in co-op and for the race it's true
lapse so for example you have a
customization you can select how many
laps you want and the first one to
complete the full circuit we'll uh we'll
get the the first place
[Music]
fantastic um
it looks like uh okay drain might be
running into some issues there but you
know okay drain you do play a lot of
retro games um
what do you think the speed running uh
potential of a game like this is
it's exciting because i'm gonna tell you
what i won't look at the rankings chart
unless i'm top 100 right but i like the
idea of playing fast
because it gives you incentive to do
your best and like i can do that faster
i can do it better and even if you can't
you know upgrade yourself to the top 100
you can ask your friends how fast you
beat that 12 seconds cool i did nine and
then never play it again
that let's just go for the perfect run
yeah
exactly go out while you're on top um
now from my understanding eon drive
follows uh this this woman who's uh
trapped on a planet and has to collect
all the drive course do you mind going
into the story just a little bit who is
she where is she from and why is she
here
well jacqueline is our protagonist and
from a narrative point of view she's
arriving to this alternative earth
after
uh the story that was uh told in our in
our first game in dimensions right i
mentioned why drive was was a shooter in
space it had nothing to do with the
gameplay that you see here but the story
picks up right after that so after
dimension drive she goes through a
portal after a big explosion
and then
eventually she winds up crash landing in
this in this
earth in this new earth
and um
while she's crash landing the
engine of the ship kind of breaks apart
and all the different cores that power
up
go in different places in the city
and the problem is that they are
unstable now and
if you don't retrieve them and bring
them back to the spaceship in time
the whole
city will explode and most likely take
out the planet even
oh so that's where the 30 second timer
comes in from fantastic
um adrian do you mind going into some of
the tools you have at your disposal to
get through the level a little bit
faster
yeah no problem so i can throw my little
sword dagger right there i cannot talk
and game at the same time i just figured
out five seconds ago
but
i have my little dagger throw to help me
get across maps faster also as you can
see when you're falling down a pit it's
nice to have that dagger in place so it
can save you last second but it allows
you to teleport to different things and
these mechanical features in the way you
press the x button get rid of those if
you run on low in time press the y
button in the capsules you have stored
in the upper right hand corner
restore your time how about i even
there's no one else in the leaderboard
except me and i'm not even like top 10.
how does that happen
this is a special version of the of a
build just for you so
you can make my own first on this build
yeah yeah thank you
it's really speaking of that
sort of uh time warping adrian um do the
devs mind going into some of like what
is the unique time warping mechanic in
eon drive
yeah it's um it's basically what avian
was explaining that um
we wanted to make the level built for
speed running
from the ground tab right so from the
very moment that we started developing
we thought we want to have all the
levels on a 30 second timer and all the
levels should be
possible to complete in that time but
then we thought we want to give also
accessibility to players that may not be
able to complete a level in 30 seconds
or they want to play more chill right
so we added this idea of you pick up
collectibles around the level these time
capsules and they accumulate on your on
your um
timer at the top
and whenever you want you can just press
y and if you have enough capsules you
can grant yourself five extra seconds
so that gives you a bit of a list less
of a challenge and allows you to
complete the level that maybe is too
difficult for you at that time or
or you just want to simply take it more
coldly right
obviously if you do that you will do a
very poor time and there goes your
competition in the leaderboards
right um eon drives kind of seems like
the game that um because i i'm not very
good at side scrolling platformers to be
completely honest i have to that's why
okay draen's playing and not me um but
one of the things i find interesting is
so you can it seems like you can go for
perfection and go for a great time
but if you hit a hard wall you can still
use these different mechanics to kind of
increase or lower the difficulty is am i
getting at that rate
yeah that's basically what we were going
for it so
everyone can enjoy the game at their own
pace and there's definitely enjoyment
for the casual player and for the ones
that really want to grind the
leaderboards and get that number one
spot
fantastic
um
i i absolutely love just the little bit
of the levels we've seen here they're
beautiful what were some of the
inspirations or challenges um when you
were designing these levels
well from a
gameplay design point of view which is
my fourth because i'm the designer
maybe later but from a gameplay design
point of view
what we wanted was to give you that
feeling of
um kind of like a labyrinth of a maze
where you are
have to search your way around it's not
like it's not your typical left to right
linear platformer where
you just
go forward and there there's your exit
you have to really navigate and find
your way around and there are
different paths and several
secrets and shortcuts and um
sometimes what we tried as well was to
make the sometimes the hardest path is
actually the fastest but it's very hard
to pull off right so
in a way it goes
tight hand in hand with that idea of
giving
players a challenge that's suitable to
their needs and so they can find a route
that they say okay this this path is
fine for me and i can make it but i see
another one that is up there and
probably is faster but it's full spikes
and saws and enemies and i'm not gonna
make it so yeah yeah i think we saw
adrian just go through one of those
adrian how are we faring on the shortcut
so
there's been a couple of moments of i
wonder if i can do that and then a
couple moments of it turns out i can't
do that
and so i've been experimenting with that
also
the timing on the walls is really really
good too i swear it looks i'm better
than what it looks like right now but
the game is really fun in terms of the
idea of where do you want to go and how
do you want to get there right
as we know right now at least it looks
like it's left to right with the idea of
which left to right you want to go to
get over there
i really enjoy that the entire time and
i feel like the hit boxes on the saw
blades and different mechanical devices
or they're generous you're not way out
there it seems like which i was scared
of
fantastic would you say that you could
see yourself like trying to perfect this
level over time
yeah absolutely because i get i get mad
at the smallest thing happens especially
i wasn't kidding earlier if a friend's
like hey did you play this yeah i did
how'd you do oh i beat your time by one
second i will legit log back in and farm
until i get my second back so absolutely
fantastic i love it um
so you said with the power sword you can
you can throw it to teleport and you can
break barriers or
enemies with it yep
that's fantastic where did oh sorry
no no you can go ahead you can go ahead
yeah i was i'm curious about the
protagonist where did she get a power
sword are we going to learn more about
like uh sort of
her background through the story of this
game i know you said it's a continuation
from another game
yeah actually the
idea of the power sword of the dagger
the teleportation dagger and where it's
coming from in the story
is stole the very start of the game so
even if you have not played uh
our previous game you will not miss
anything narrative wise so um
i
would prefer not to spoil it
but
uh it's right at the very start after
the first tutorial where uh
they explain how she
gets that dagger
perfect i'll say it's a bit funny
because it's
it's more than a dagger and you will
find out why if you play this i'm
excited to i'm excited to play the
beginning now because knowing me i'm i'm
not as as good as adrian at two
seconds
not true are you kidding me you're great
everything you touched
i hope i hope it's at the beginning
because i might get stuck there but it
seems like there's a lot of ways to
adjust the difficulty
to help you get through um are there
other mechanics on top of the time
mechanic to that kind of help that
difficulty slider kind of move back and
forth
uh basically like we were mentioning
before there's different
paths that you can take each level has
more than a way of getting to the to the
finishing line so if you find yourself
always dying in the same obstacle not
really getting through you can try and
experiment with different ways to beat a
certain level
uh and also with the with the pvp mode
you can then embrace a more you know
party game almost side of it we've been
having a lot of fun with testing it
internally
and it turned into a bit of a you know a
friendly competition between between us
at the studio so if you ever feel stuck
in the in the single player you can
either summon a friend to help you or
you can go to the pvp mode and you know
enjoy a little bit more of a of a party
party game type of feel
when this come out
okay thank you so much for telling us
about eon drive this game is fantastic
would you like to leave our audience
with any last words about something you
feel like they need to know about the
game
well i'm just that if they like it they
they might check it out there's there's
a demo available
now and
on xbox and um
just that that we hope they like it and
they they get to play the game uh later
in fall when we release
fantastic thank you so much for joining
us today eon drive looks absolutely
amazing
thank you for everything
thanks for having us
bye
oh that looks so cool oh thank you so
much oh thank you so much to the folks
yeah to eon drive and thank you so much
that okay adrian we got like you tried
your best but we were watching we were
rooting for you see him just sync like
they were the gameplay wasn't even
showing i just wonder what exactly
happened he just bitched so hard
oh my gosh oh so uh so megan what did
you think of eon drive
uh it looks like so much fun listen i
grew up playing a lot of platformers as
a kid mega man was like my first crush
ever so uh those kind of games are just
super nostalgic for me i could just like
my brain does something i can dial in
and just go through and jam no problem
um what about you steve what do you
think i it looked actually really cool
like i love cyberpunk that's kind of
like one of my favorite genres the
matrix is my favorite movie of all time
um and it's kind of had it kind of had
that plus celeste kind of vibes to it
and i love it exactly yeah
oh it just had like i had like a really
really awesome vibe to it and i love
that this is going to be a game for
speedrunners like this feels like it's
like okay you know what one more round
another 30 seconds let's see if we will
try to try to beat my time like i love
that so much
yeah no no me too i feel like people are
gonna have a lot of fun with it
especially the pvp mode they were
talking about that's a new element and i
i like where they're going with it
yeah and i love the call-out for
accessibility it just warms my heart to
be able to hear that especially with the
ability like yes 30 seconds that's kind
of a very finite time but being able to
pick up those kind of like time capsules
to add extra time for you so it's not as
a difficult experience i love that at
least they're thinking devs are thinking
about that and oh it just it just warms
this blind gamer's heart
i love that too gaming is for everyone
and i love that everybody is like
bringing more attention to it and making
that possible um okay so up next we have
another exclusive trailer for you let's
take a look
at the big khan
[Music]
hi i'm dave proctor founder of mightyl
studios our new game the big con is a
cross-country 90s adventure about ali a
teenage girl doing petty crimes to save
her mom's video store from loan sharks
last time we showed you auditions from
award-winning video game actors bringing
depth and range to our
let's call it economical voice over
script there's dialogue dialogue
dialogue dialogue it's like 13 words
today we're going to reveal some very
exciting casting choices every character
ally meets in the big con is lovingly
handcrafted with 90s charm and artisanal
quirkiness from charismatic con artists
to pekish mall security to skateboard
and ghosts our best in class dialogue
demands the apex of voice talent but
first a very special announcement the
big con is available for pre-order right
now on xbox xbox series x and xbox
series s before it launches worldwide on
august 31st before we get into our big
casting announcement i also want to
congratulate the fans who answered our
open casting call to voice our games
npcs we watched all of your submissions
and were moved by your creativity and
passion you can't hear the word hey
repeated 1600 times without feeling
something
i am so tired
anyways here are some of our winners
well
hoyle
what
really
and now the big reveal we are pleased to
announce that our protagonist ally will
be voiced by none other than erica ishii
we've been fans of erica's for a long
time now we're beyond thrilled to work
with one of the hardest working and most
positive actors in the industry erica
anything to add hi erica ishii here yeah
i'm just so psyched to be here you know
like
there's just something so raw and real
about these kinds of characters and this
kind of indie game it's like black box
theater you know all the prestige the
drama the you know you create the
circumstances and your surroundings you
think about the character get real deep
in their head only you know you uh
you get paid but that's not all also
joining erica and our celebrated voice
cast is dave fenoy legendary actor and
the voice behind so many iconic video
game characters he'll be playing one of
my favorite characters rad ghost the
entire voice over is about a dozen words
and assorted monosyllabic grunts
ah come on man
what are you trying to do to me thanks
for watching don't forget to pre-order
the big con today on xbox series x xbox
series s and xbox one and play it at
launch on august 31st we're gonna party
like it's 1994.
[Music]
that looks so cool that looks like
something i would write for blockbuster
i know exactly like i love the 90s vibes
i don't know if you caught it but the
theme song if you're a 90s kid you know
who this group is rocapella from where
in the world is carmen san diego they're
doing the theme song for the big con for
that one so that's
that's just so cool the fact that also
we got a really cool cast erica ishii we
got troy baker we got defennoy legends
in the like in the gaming industry ah
that's so cool i love that everyone in
chat press one if you if you're you're
down to play it i'm gonna pre-order it i
can't wait i'm gonna 100 and it comes
out at the end of this month that's so
cool
all right so coming up we're about to
take a quick break but let's take a look
at the schedule again to see what's
coming up
so we've got some cool stuff that's
still available still to come uh
unfortunately we've got
yeah we're just getting started we have
about another but just you know what
just a little bit about an hour uh left
for some cool really cool stuff we've
got stuff from the veil um shadow of the
crown it's a really cool audio game
we're gonna be checking out um we've got
some other cool trailers and stuff that
we haven't seen yet before
valley stardew valley uh and then uh we
also have a game demo of space lines
from the far out
and just so many trailer reveals i'm
just not gonna be able to contain it i'm
writing i hope everyone's taking notes
writing down games that they can't wait
to play it's gonna be me i'm gonna be
playing all of these but uh we got a
break right
yes all right so we'll be right back
after a quick break
welcome back everyone i'm strawberry 17
plays hanging out with the blind gamer
steve and we have so much fun stuff
coming up for you guys ain't that right
dude yes
oh my gosh i love that hi i'm steve
saylor aka blind gamer steve and uh
we've just we're just getting started
we're about halfway through still got
another hour of some really cool
trailers we've got uh some really cool
like a cool game plays coming up and
including uh some more
i started ali stardew valley
um and we've also got some game pass
announcements folks that's right game
pass announcements literally my favorite
words of this year is day one on game
pass and i love it so freaking much
i i i'm so excited for that i just i
gotta tell you game pass is like my
netflix so whenever i'm like in a mood
i'm like i go to game pass and i just
peruse download three games and just you
know
live my best life so not gonna lie i i
was i was uh during the xbox showcase at
uh e3 this year i was like almost drunk
getting like seeing all the amount of
times they said day one on game pass 27
new games coming out to game pass and uh
that's really awesome but today i mean
that's just xbox in general today we're
talking about indies at the uh for the
id uh at xbox um and so we're gonna jump
into a game right now that uh i've known
about for a while um but i'm really
really excited to finally be able to sit
down with uh with this developer our
next guest is the director of the vail
shadow of the crown an audio based
action adventure game that places you in
the worn leather boots of a blind
adventurer the veil is an incredible
interactive experience that'll impress
visually impaired and sighted gamers
alike before we meet dave evans let's
take a look at the trailer
[Music]
escort a blind girl 500 miles down a
treacherous valley in the wake of an
invading world
not sure what reward would be worth that
pirates
[Music]
i know you can use the damn thing dark
swinging girl
in the dark we shine alex
every one of us serves the fame whether
we know it or not i will not serve them
that is why you must die
adriana told me you were coming
a blind princess
doomed to watch her kingdom burn
if you want the kingdom
you will have to take it from me
yourself
from one second born to another it's not
an easy thing being in someone's shadow
i like the shadows
[Music]
not gonna lie
i've got a little bit for clumped a
little bit emotional in that i i
i am just so excited megan would back in
just a second but i'm going to be
sitting down with dave evans dave
welcome to the show thank you so much
for joining us
yeah uh really nice to be here nice to
meet you steve uh finally i've been
watching your career as well at the same
time it's been great
uh i i mean i gotta okay
revelation chat i mean uh like hometown
represent st catharines ontario canada
my hometown and and uh like mighty
yell's hometown i love that uh so much
and i i feel like i've kind of heard
about the veil for for a while now and
it like being an audio only game i've
been always i've been interested in
wanting to try it out and uh when the
game came out last year as a demo for
summer game showcase i i was
summer game fast i was i downloaded
immediately and i played it and i've
probably played it several times now um
and like it's really truly an amazing uh
audio experience so dave my first
question for you is what was the
inspiration behind um the the that sort
of creating an audio narrative uh for
the game
yeah as an indie dev um i have limited
resources and my
my first uh
uh reason for making the game was
relatively pragmatic i i was trying to
think of an inexpensive way i could
really work with story and uh
it uh wasn't soon before i realized i
might have something in doing it in all
audio that might uh be accessible and
interesting to the blind community
um and that's where everything started
with with a trip to the cnib in canada
it's a canadian national institute for
the blind and basically partnered up
with the black community from the
beginning to to make this game but it
started for fairly selfish reasons to be
honest i just wanted to make a game i
could afford to make
i i love that um and now you're so
you're from uh falling squirrel studios
i apologize i call the uh mighty yell
that's from the big con another toronto
amazing canadian developer that we just
saw earlier um so what is falling
squirrels can uh connection to the blind
low vision communities you mentioned the
cnib um which i i'm a big proponent of
and and a member of um so how did like
how did that work when trying to be able
to look into developing uh
the game
uh well i mean they were my first uh
focus testing group a testing group um
and uh
in a strange way uh the evolution of
this game over the last five years
really is about uh myself and this
community making a game for everyone uh
it sort of to me lost it's uh it wasn't
as important of the accessibility aspect
as it was that's a chance for me to
showcase an audio based game uh made by
community who's very familiar with them
so they were my first instructors and
teachers on how to make this game um so
we had
live
testing groups where i got feedback made
friends uh there was a person at the
cnib martin curcells who uh was an avid
gamer and he became one of my many
consultants on the project so for me it
was the beginning of a relationship with
the community uh and the development of
game
i love that and i know that there's
there's definitely some um sort of like
obviously for those who may not need it
uh like for uh for for those that's in
the blind community having an audio game
um is something that that we there's a
there's a few audio games out there and
there's some um amazing if you search on
google there's some amazing amazing
audio games uh but like the veil is kind
of like something that just kind of
appeals to me in that if you're if
you're interested in kind of like have
you ever heard old-time radio shows or
think of this as like a very like and
it's very bare bones like like an
interactive uh audiobook um but like
it's it's that kind of vibe and uh the
like the i want to talk about actually
kind of the the audio engineering and
sort of the cast that you have in there
because it is like there's some amazing
sort of soundscapes uh and uh and
obviously uh voice acting in this um
is it like did you approach that from
like a kind of like an audio sort of
old-school
all-time radio sort of vibe to it when
you first sort of kind of were thinking
about the story
uh well two things one is i i used to
work in triple a as a cinematographer
and a motion capture and audio director
so uh i my first place to go was was
triple a sound design from from a uh
casting uh and performance uh
perspective so i just pictured pretended
i was i was making a naughty dog game or
or any kind of big action adventure game
uh and
really didn't didn't uh compromise on
on the casting and that sort of thing um
so that was my starting point was was
film sensibilities and triple a
sensibilities uh but then as as i made
the game i realized that there was there
was a layer that that's that's novel and
different which is the intimacy and
that's where i think it does play out
more like uh what you see in podcasts
now uh narrative-based podcasts or or
old-school radio shows there's something
about having an actor standing in front
of you or feeling like they're they're
in your companion is literally
whispering in your ear and enemies are
literally breathing around you and that
novelty uh was very different than than
how you usually uh make a aaa production
where where you're really supporting
visuals this just allowed us to do
things i'd never considered doing before
like having someone whisper near breathe
in your ear or or or create moments of
intimacy like like we have in this game
yeah and speaking of which you
definitely want to be able to play this
with headphones dawn because there is
just an amazing sort of 3d kind of audio
landscape that um that you all kind of
like created which is so cool um and
here's actually a question from uh from
the chat um can you actually explain how
the gameplay works and how do players
actually play the game
yeah there's two major components uh as
in many action adventures there's an
element of of uh action which is
supplied by combat uh which uh there's
several different scenarios for combat
uh the most popular one is uh basically
combat in place where you're standing
and hearing a 3d soundscape or really a
180 degree soundscape enemies very
kindly don't stand directly behind you
um and you can hear enemy movement you
can hear uh the attacks that they're
about to do and it's a directional uh uh
swing uh stick stick swinging and um and
uh timing and pattern recognition like a
mike tyson punch out or something like
that um and then the other aspect of the
game uh is the
exploration aspect uh so when you walk
into a village to uh find quests or
buy items or explore the world uh you're
left into a 3d environment environment
where you can hear little details in the
soundscape the the ones you really are
really important uh like the beacons
like the tavern or something else like a
blacksmith they're very obvious and easy
to navigate to and then everything else
is rewards for people willing to to
carefully listen the the dog begging in
the corner you can go and feed him and
he becomes a companion you can get
quests from from people sort of like
this old woman washing clothes by down
by a dock and if you go up to her you
can get a quest from her so um it's it's
a balance of discovery uh rewarding uh
uh discovery um and just enjoying uh
moving around uh navigating in complete
audio
uh i i love that and uh as someone who
played it like it's kind of one of those
really cool things when you're kind of
in this sort of town
and you have like you sort of hear
different sort of like merchants kind of
calling out to people in the crowd
around you and you hear like the
blacksmith and you can just kind of turn
sort of like using the thumbs to kind of
turn your character and you can be able
to kind of walk towards it it just uses
audio to kind of like navigate um and it
can seem a little bit overwhelming at
first but like when you kind of like
sort of take the time to kind of like
listen to certain things you can kind of
like just explore which is something
that's that's really really cool in just
an audio
only game um so uh one final question i
actually do have for you um in like it's
obviously this may this seems like a
very kind of narrative experience um in
terms of replayability what is there to
keep gamers going back uh to the veil
for more yeah the big one for me anyway
is we have a very hard
hard mode in this game um so my
recommendation uh is to play the game
there is some branching narrative there
are aspects of the game uh that force
you to make some minor decisions um but
uh the the main aspect of replay i think
is to go back and try the hard mode i do
not recommend starting with the hard
mode uh in the game uh but uh it's one
of those things where once you get very
very comfortable playing the game it's
something people should try so that that
to me is probably the biggest reason to
go back is challenge yourself and by the
way this was demanded by the blind
community to make it very very hard i i
think they may have been disappointed by
other things in the past that that
weren't quite difficult enough so um be
warned hard mode is hard
i love that and that's something that
like not a lot of people sort of even
like a lot of people understand regards
to accessibility it's like when we want
to have accessibility in games we don't
want to lose that challenge we still
want to have the same challenge as every
other player has and some of our friends
have when they play we just want to be
able to have at least some of the
barriers kind of taken away so um like i
for myself i played it on normal and it
was it was it was it was a challenge in
there too but i'm like now i'm curious
to kind of see what the hard mode is
like so uh i'm really uh interested in
that so dave um once thank you so much
for joining us where can we find more
information
about the veil uh when is it coming out
any any details you can be able to offer
uh our chat
yeah it's it's coming out this this
august 19th um and uh
followingscroll.com the website you can
check us out there um but it's gonna be
available on the xbox uh day one august
19th so that's that's where you should
be looking i think
fantastic i can't wait to play this on
uh on the full game on xbox uh once
again thank you dave so much uh for
joining us
uh i'm a little emotional about it but i
appreciate you so much and and i can't
wait to be able to rep uh our hometown
and and being able to play this game uh
for for everyone it's uh well done sir
well well done yep thanks steve
awesome thank you so much all right so
in a moment um megan is going to be
joining me to rejoin me to on the id at
xbox showcase but before that
we have some more trailer reviews for
you right now next up the moment we've
all been waiting for here are the games
that are coming to game pass
let's take a look
[Music]
ah
[Music]
my own demise
was the only way to free myself
i too was a slave
a tool used by the akatsuchi in their
conquest of the land
but not anymore
death
led me to the place where i belong
[Music]
we need to find the key to our disease
free ourselves from this curse
our enemies have already enslaved
countless of our kind
we
must liberate them all
[Music]
our time has come
the time
of the kuru superclan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
100 years
for 100 years we have been plagued by
this war we fight we sacrifice we die
before us a host of monstrosities and
behind us all of galerion our world
their master the demon lord daskari
thinks he can break our spirit he is
mistaken
we did not yield when our cities burned
when our fortresses were turned to dust
and our comrades our brothers and
sisters in arms valiantly met their
deaths
we have suffered through many a plight
and now it is our turn to strike
two arms brothers and sisters
i declare that the fifth crusade has
begun and it is you who will lead us in
this war
duty calls to you prove your worth as a
leader hone your skills and abilities
ready your best armor and weapons for
battle
mount your trusty wall steed and charge
force and we shall follow
this will be a daunting task i know
but you need not fight alone
your faithful companions will stand by
your side
they will protect you in battle
aid you with their counsel
share the burden of commanding the
crusade
accept their friendship and become their
friend in turn or possibly something
more
i understand the trials ahead of you are
great
you will have to find your own path
what will be the source of your power
the righteous might of heaven or the
secrets of forbidden magic
will you make your sacrifices in the
name of freedom and equality or in the
name of law and order will your enemies
flee at the very sight of you or will
you perhaps turn this entire war into a
grand joke on a cosmic scale
choose carefully your every decision has
its consequences and its price
but most importantly
never doubt that valerian believes in
you
and i
i believe in you as well
do you feel the ground shaking
that is the march of your army
lead them aim them at their target crush
our enemies
we are crusaders
we are the wrath of the righteous
the stakes have never been higher we did
not seek out this war it invaded our
home and our world now depends on you
and you alone
[Music]
rated everyone
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
product not yet rated
[Music]
[Applause]
we will crush them
yes it is
i want that minnie and dead
you're nothing
hey
time to earn
[Music]
um
[Music]
let the madness begin
[Music]
xbox we have dogs who skateboard and you
get to make them have eyelashes
yep exactly and then you get to be an
evil genius and you get to also be like
an amazing ninja and you get to like
play in one of the greatest tt rpgs
other than dnd we got bath finder uh
pillars of eternity vibes i'm so i'm so
in
i just really love the world that we're
living in right now i'm just i'm just
gonna say that
uh
blind gamer steve you're gonna be
rejoining us in just a second but uh
right now i am honored to welcome to the
idea xbox showcase the creator of
stardew valley eric barone aka concerned
ape and if you've been living under a
rock for the last few years and aren't
familiar with stardew valley well uh
here's a trailer
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
great thank you so much for joining us
thank you it's great to be here
yeah uh i never thought this moment
would happen where i'd be talking to you
and i'm i'm i'm not gonna make this work
i promise i'm not gonna be too big of a
fan girl but i have sunk like over a
thousand hours into stardew valley and
it's what inspired me to start getting
into pixel art so i'm sure you sure the
stuff all the time but you're an
inspiration to so many people and you've
created a game that is just
it's so special
um
when you released it obviously you
weren't anticipating this type of
uh
you know feedback but what can you what
was that feeling like that you worked on
this for by yourself for so long and
then you released it out into the world
and you're like oh they like it we'll
see what happens i'm proud of it but i
don't know
like yeah i mean that would it totally
blew my mind i mean as you say i had no
idea the game was going to be so popular
i thought it would be like a really
niche game
for people who are fans of harvest moon
like me
um
and i just re i guess it struck a chord
with people but i i had no idea so it
really blew my mind it took me a while
many years to get used to
you know how popular stardew valley was
and how many people seem to really love
it
but
it's amazing i mean i'm so glad people
like it
yeah
you created like this really nice home
for people to come back to it's i uh
i grew up playing a lot of nintendo as a
kid so um having those those games that
you just like you spent so much time
with almost feels like a distant family
member or like a best friend i feel like
stardoo is that for so many people
they'll they can sink all these hours
into it take a break and then come back
and be like ah yes
i'm home
yeah yeah when i was a kid i played a
lot of rpgs and i feel like most of the
rpgs send you on this big grand
adventure where you leave your home and
travel all around the world on a big
adventure but
i always was more drawn to harvest moon
because it was kind of domestic like you
made a home for yourself you stayed at
home and then there was a lot of depth
to the home that you were living in and
so for some reason that just really
resonated with me and i wanted to
capture that feeling and
you know hopefully give
a new generation of people um that same
magic that i felt as a kid when i was
playing harvest moon
i think you've succeeded um
i think another thing that makes sturdy
valley so special is uh all the people
um do you have a favorite
uh character in town
like who do you want
i can't pick a favorite character
no the i think the other characters
would get jealous if i yeah no okay okay
that's fair can you guess mine i'm just
i'm throwing it up there
let me guess um abigail
oh my gosh how'd you know
is that is that true
yes it's abigail how did you know i'm
like warring with my friend we have a
co-op and we're ruining
it's just a intuition i don't know
i have abigail
i guess so yeah
oh my goodness that just that you just
killed me right now
um
let's talk about like bigger picture uh
just real quick um
how
did you ever expect arduino to make such
an impact on the gaming industry because
now there's so many games that are in
the same vein just like a harvest moon
inspired you people are looking at sardi
valley and they're like yes this is
beautiful what's my take on it
um no i i had no idea but i mean it's
it's really cool i
i feel like i'm continuing a tradition
that you know yasuhiro wada started with
harvest moon
um or at least that's my hope i would
like to continue that tradition and to
see
you know a new generation of game
developers
you know
bringing that tradition even further and
expanding on it with new ideas and new
things is is great it's really cool to
be a part of that
and i'm glad to see the genre really
taking off
no it's great i these are the kind of
games that i live for um are there any
other like farming type games that also
uh
that you love playing that have come out
recently all right i mean i imagine
you're a pretty busy dude
it's true i i am pretty busy i haven't
had a lot of chance to play um
a lot of the games that people call like
you know stardew valley inspired games
um
i played some slime rancher for a while
which
i wouldn't say is inspired by sweaty
valleys it was you know being developed
in parallel but i feel like it it also
is a bit of that kind of like you know
resource gathering
kind of home base sort of game
yeah that was pretty cool
does it bother you when people call
sardo like a farming sim because it's so
much more i don't know maybe i'm
protective i feel like it's so much more
than that you don't get it
no it doesn't bother me i mean i i would
call it i call it like a country life
simulator
yeah or like you know something like
that but it doesn't really bother me i
mean people can call it whatever they
want yeah yeah yeah well would you ever
move into a farm or i'm sorry would you
ever move out to a place like pelican
town can you see this being like your
retirement plan someday
yeah absolutely i think that they're i
think uh all humans have a call to
nature
and maybe that's part of the reason why
stardew valley resonated with people
it's a kind of a
something in the modern world that we
don't experience very often you know the
being out in nature being out in the
country living off the land that sort of
thing
yeah i think it does speak to us on a
deep level
it does being a stranger in a new place
and learning uh about other people
outside of yourself and kind of just
getting a new beginning i think that's
something a lot of us especially with
the internet are like man i wonder what
it's like for no one to know me uh and
get that fresh start i sometimes have
dreams of like working at a grocery
store and just bagging groceries that's
like something i never got to do as a
teenager i worked at a chicken wing
place i i worked at i did everything
else a skateboard shop but i was like
when i play stardew valley i'm like i
want to work at jojo mart
i bet someone's working on a grocery
bagging simulator as we speak oh my gosh
that's it i just need to put my vr
headset on and then i'll just be in the
world and just living my best life
um quick question uh you released a
bunch of new updates not too long ago
um how's the feedback and response been
about that
you're just constantly working on this
game
yeah it's been great the uh the most
recent update 1.5 um
has been
the i i would i call it the biggest
update to sardi valley ever i'm which it
is objectively but it it seems like
people really loved it and the game kind
of had a new resurgence in popularity
after the update came out so i've been
really happy with the response to that i
think the update it adds a huge amount
of stuff to the game especially the end
game um
and yeah it's it's
releasing the updates is kind of like
you know i i'm of the mindset that i
could probably continue working on
stardew valley forever with the amount
of ideas i have and just
you know
i love the world i love making it better
um i feel like it's a never-ending thing
i could do to make it better but
you know so i just put those ideas in
these updates and just keep the game
going and it's been fun
well
as a fan and a long time player i
appreciate all of your hard work
sleepless nights and probably the
extreme amount of coffee you have to sip
through and the way that your brain
works because it's just it's an amazing
game and it's so great to always come
back to but eric
i hear you have some exciting news about
stardew valley
that's true that's true so uh i'm i'm
happy to announce that starde valley
will be coming to game pass
uh there's not like a yeah there's not a
set release date yet but it's probably
sometime in the fall
um and it'll be on both windows and xbox
consoles
um
yeah so i'm i'm happy to announce that
and i i really hope that it uh
you know bring stardew valley to a lot
more people and a lot more people get to
play it and experience the world of
stardew valley
co-op man let's go everyone get xbox
game pass
gta is leaving so i just feel like
you're gonna get all the gta people just
uh they're gonna start to simmer down
and just you know start a farm and be
like all right i like this star do it
yeah that's the life for me
all right eric thank you so much it was
a pleasure meeting you thank you uh for
everything that you do um
i don't even know how to say goodbye to
you i just want to keep talking
thanks for stopping by thank you it's
nice to meet you and uh thanks for
having me on appreciate it and have a
great day you too
okay bye
all right in a moment i'll be uh
rejoined by blind gamer steve but before
that
there's time
or it is time for another exclusive
trailer let's take a look at a library
of aruna
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
right ah i love it it's kind of got like
some jrpg kind of vibes with some uh
some like card based sort of battle like
like oh man
i love the japanese voice acting anytime
i can like practice my japanese and i'm
always alive i'd love to do it love to
be immersed in it
hell yeah and like for myself personally
usually uh subtitled games or even like
like uh subtitled anime is a little bit
difficult for me to be able to read but
at least what i loved at least there
were some good decent-sized subtitles so
i'm i'm i'm happy about it what that
means right
what what does that mean
all right we gotta learn japanese
together because
but i can
we can we can make i listen i'm your
uncle i remember i told you yes you
didn't know we were going to start
playing indie games but i'm also going
to teach you japanese as i'm still
learning it because i'm only on like
chapter one of pimsleur's so
oh i love that so much i knew there was
a i knew there was a good reason to be
here today oh no
oh my gosh that's awesome now let's talk
about okay
stardew valley for game pass
i was within i was in the chat okay and
i was like at first i was kind of like
okay i understand that the stardew
valley big huge game
totally get that but as the chat was
kind of going through i was following
along and i was like uh okay okay all
right i'm in
and then it's like then i started to see
like some of the pelican town stands and
i'm like are citizens and i'm like i
kind of want i kind of want to play this
now i think you have you all kind of
sold me on and it's going to be coming
to game pass i love that you could do
co-op too like you can start a farm with
friends and go through the entire story
mode and work on all of the achievements
and unlockables together and there's all
these secrets and the narrative is just
the storyline is so good that's why you
play it i could get emotional talking
about sardi valley i'm not gonna lie i i
travel a lot post before covet i would
be traveling all the time i would be
home maybe a week out of the month and
it's just like me and my nintendo switch
and stardew was like my second home when
i felt homesick or was like a little
lonely that's what i would play so it's
it's special to a lot of people and i
think once you play it you'll experience
that too
i totally get that and like i know we're
showing a library of runa right now and
like again this game just kind of looks
really really cool um i i love the
aesthetic i love the vibe um it like is
like is there like an equivalent type of
game uh like a jrpg kind of game that
you can sort of uh like what what what's
what am i should be like just looking at
this gameplay footage what should i be
expecting uh when it looks like when i'm
only playing library aruna
um chat what do you what would you say
this game kind of uh if
it's kind of similar to you i'm trying
to think of the name uh and it's
escaping me it was on xbox game pass it
it's not uh
it's not the yakuza game i i'm i'm
drawing a blank i've only had half a cup
of coffee today
that's okay
slay the spire is what someone is saying
slay the spire okay oh and i didn't
realize aruna is actually korean okay
that's even that that's cool as well i
think that's actually pretty dope uh i i
i know i love the aesthetic and you know
what growing up
i mean i don't know like i have no idea
if this has anything to do with the
library but it's like okay growing up i
used to go to the library all the time
and uh i love the kind of like
i don't know it's just like the stories
kind of set in the library or set kind
of like around like sort of book
learning or just like book reading
always kind of appeal to me and here's
i'm not like i'm not a huge kind of like
uh like this this game normally would
not appeal to me but after like looking
at this trailer kind of like and and the
gameplay
i don't know i getting i think i'm kind
of like it's kind of bringing back a
little bit of nostalgia as a kid not
gonna lie
yeah yeah did you play a lot of final
fantasy
so i did play a little bit as a kid but
again it was sort of like it was kind of
hard for me to play um so i did jump
into final fantasy 7 remake
when that came out and i started to
really enjoy it and i was kind of like
trying to be able to look into other um
sort of games like that and it seemed
like there was a lot of like everyone
kept recommending persona everyone kept
recommending final fantasy 6 as well
like just in that series um so it's like
if the
the growing interest is there like
there's the seed has been planted it's
just i need to kind of like grow that
and fertilize it just to kind of like
get it like to get to a point where i'm
like i really want to be able to like
jump into this kind of genre head-on and
maybe hey library aruna might might be
the way into that um and oh yeah and
thermal wolf actually in the chat says
he has a bit of like octopus travel
vibes i can i can understand that i can
totally understand that um and oh
oh this is a cool idea so uh vinox 123
says can i rent a vhs in that library i
wonder if that's the case because i used
to remember vhs all the time and from
the library
little games with within the game you
know like just like you're like yeah
this is like the game dev is just like
hey why not let's just let's add a
little something extra in here
yeah exactly and uh spiraling 100 seed
of like germination
it's perfect that's perfect
i was speaking about japanese you said
jrpg and my brain just went there i'm so
sorry about that guys
that's okay i mean i'm like i'm the
newbie here so i apologize for that as
well um so that's really cool all right
so up next we're gonna go in right into
a gameplay demo twitch gaming regular
snowlit is going to join us for a live
gameplay demonstration of the upcoming
game space lines from the far out and
we'll be joined by the devs before we
welcome everyone on the id at xbox
showcase let's take a look at the
trailer
this trailer brought to you by adam dyne
gravity generator keep your feet on the
ground and your lunch inside your
stomach
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
uh please welcome co-founder of coffee
knots fabio rosa and twitch's very own
snow lit thanks for joining us guys
hello thanks for having us
that was such a cool oh my gosh i have
like i i have like oh this is gonna need
i love the concept of basically kind of
so i'm taking something just normal day
life you know just getting on a plane
having like having a little bit of an
airline and then if you add space into
it like
that's all you need to do
that's exactly it oh my gosh
having been so popular this last year
it's just not i just like keep me in
space i'm a big trekkie so you know and
i love star wars too so any time space
is in the equation i'm like beam me up
i'm ready
i love that so fabio what you can you
tell us about uh space lines how does it
all work
uh well so uh
this game by the way is our first game
it started out as a student project so
it's uh i'm really happy to be here
thanks guys and uh
well on its surface it's kind of like a
it's a retro futuristic game about uh
the space age of the 60s and the kind of
golden
pan am era of air travel
like you see in like a catch me if you
can
but so that's on the surface and at its
core
it's like a it's a game for people who
love that kind of a
co-op party game experience but wish it
also featured stuff like elements of
progression uh
the ability to unlock stuff
dynamically generated challenges like a
kind of like a roguelike game so there
are no predetermined levels you just
have to improvise and
be the best space flight crew you can be
so i mean i guess to i guess the best
way to summarize it is like if it's the
love child of
overcooked and faster than light that's
it
i love those clothes
so
uh
snowy are you ready to try a live
gameplay demo of this yes i actually got
to play the tutorial last night and it's
just really fun the things you can do on
your ship you can customize so much like
you can even change the name of your
crew
which is really awesome like just look
here you can just generate different
names like it's just really really fun
like i'm enjoying all the little cute
details and things you can do
i love little i should say that this is
a
the demo version of the game which is a
local multiplayer version of it is now
available for free on the xbox store
people can test it out so it's a demo so
it's like it's a portion of the game's
mechanics it has one campaign one
starter ship and a few upgrades
uh but yeah it's going to be live
on the xbox store for the entirety of
the month so yeah whoever wants to play
that looks cool
so uh so fabio if you don't mind me
asking like so like uh what were you
doing before uh you decided to start
coffee nights because you said this is
your first game so what was uh what was
your experience uh in game development
before
uh
well i i i worked briefly uh
at a studio uh in a game studio in
brazil but that was while i was already
making the game
uh but before that i wasn't an english
teacher like uh
yeah like i have a bunch of people in my
team there used to be other things like
cashier
baker
and then we kind of met at this uh
this really cool uh school that we have
here in sao paulo and
we learned how to make games there and
this project started there
so yeah
wow
i i love that so much the fact like
that's the power of the idea of xbox
program is that like
anybody could be able to like if you
want to be able to make a game and you
totally can do that there's a resource
to do that and this just looks really
really cool so uh snow that what are
your what are you uh accomplishing what
is your objectives right now that you're
trying to be able to do
so it looks like we're going to another
station
right and so you have your your crew
here it looks like you can navigate you
can scan for different things there's a
lot of asteroids and and i guess you
could run into them but if you you
probably shouldn't but
uh you can repair your ship if you do
uh you can also dance in this game which
i think is really really cute it's like
a little rhythm game built in yes we got
to show you hold on once we get back to
the game
i got to see the dancing
it's like actually quite kingdom game
yeah and you do it
like just just press the prompt when oh
if you mess up then your character kind
of sweats but
it's really cute just like real life
just like real life
um
yeah
a cool part of this
like it's a since it's a non-violent
game it's hard to have like kind of
enemies and it's hard to like make the
make the player fail if you're not doing
a good service to your passengers so we
created this villain who is the health
inspector like if you're doing bad he
shows up
in his little scooter and the one way
you can distract him is with the dance
so that's a very important aspect of
this mechanic
i love that
oh that is so cool oh my gosh oh wow
wait why why did you decide you guys are
going the wrong way i think
yeah we should probably have somebody
driving
well i mean you woke up and you chose
chaos
obviously
um why did you decide on uh an
intergalactic travel company
well uh that's a good question but i
think
there's something about uh
like there's a bunch of retro-futuristic
games out there and uh we have the
impression that they're usually based on
uh futurism from the 40s or like from
the 70s and both of those are very dark
and like in the 40s everything about
space was scary in the 70s everything
about space was scary as well again
because of aliens and stuff like that so
uh uh
we were really we we thought that there
should be a game that was
as optimistic about like this colorful
weird magical space like in the 60s like
yeah watch jetsons like it seems so cool
you want to live there you know
why don't we have the pills that you
could put in the microwave yet like you
know like how they did on the justin's
and that turns into food i'm sorry it's
so amazing
so what are the like what are the kind
of so when you're when you're on a
flight what are kind of the the core
tasks that you have to be able to uh to
do because this kind of has like a bit
of like an overcooked uh kind of five uh
vibe fix mixed with like ftl i think it
was i was mentioned in chat earlier um
so yeah what are the kind of things you
have to do while you're uh flying to
your destination
so uh
we love overcooked and one of one of the
key different uh one of the key
differences between uh
these games is that uh
we uh everything in the games is
procedural including the events that
happen so you have all your tools and
the little systems in the ship and the
stuff you can do but what happens is
actually dictated by this ai which is
controlling what is happening during the
trip if somebody gets sick and start to
puke or if there's more asteroids or
comets or less results so you kind of
have to improvise with the stuff you
have so you can
pilot the ship you can
navigate using the map you can dance you
can cook you can uh
like we try to get these tropes from
sci-fi like redirect power to shields
yeah that kind of stuff so you can
control the power uh
uh and mainly you have to handle the
passengers so if they're getting bored
they start they might start like
pushing buttons and uh turning off the
gravity
can you eject them can you send them out
if you're just like you know what this
one's too rowdy
this is the number one most requested
feature we have and it's weird uh i
think that says something about
the little one
you gotta get stuff done if someone's
causing trouble you
they get the boot all right yeah yeah
yeah
you don't want to be rude to the flight
titans here
well uh and uh but if you are rude to
the passengers
the inspector will show up and he's
scared he's a big guy
then you just dance off and he's just
like oh look at those moves
and then yeah
which is really fun to watch
i love that so snowy like what uh we got
it i saw that there was like your
passengers were bored for a little bit
um oh did you actually make it looks
like you kind of made it we did we
almost ran out of fuel it was a close
wow
nice nicely done wow that is just so
cool delayed but we still made it
congratulations
hey you know what it's as you keep
playing like your time can only get uh
be able to get better from there um so
like like what were uh phobia if i'm
asking what were some of the influences
for the animation style uh for for this
game
um
well um
the animation style it's uh
we wanted it to be uh
because we have a lot of different
characters so we have to kind of figure
out the animation again every time we
have like this different alien with
three eyes or like this
muscular alien or this
bug alien so um
uh it's really cool to see like how rick
and morty does it like because they have
a lot of different species of aliens
every episode and they have like their
different ways of moving
and uh
yeah really i mean uh futurama rick and
morty all these kind of like comedy
sci-fi shows yeah yeah they are great
influence
you did a fantastic job there you got it
you got us to the uh to our destination
looks like you're about to go on another
trip um but uh if uh before we say uh
goodbye fabio like what can we we can
chat and be able to expect to be able to
play the game
uh well so uh
so as i said right now we have this demo
which is a public and free
by the way the game is in beta so we're
inviting everyone watching to go and
play and give us feedback we have a form
we set up in our discord server so go
there and make suggestions uh we're
probably gonna get a lot of uh can i
kick out the passengers uh but uh sorry
we're ready
so
other than that uh it's coming uh fall
this year on xbox and pc uh and uh we're
actually right now we're opening a
mailing list on a website
for the pre-order of the special first
class edition is going to have
a bunch of cool content and it's going
to be available for purchase uh really
soon
and yeah
so i guess
if you like
comedy sci-fi like futurama rick and
morty or if you actually lived through
the 60s like the comedy sci-fi that was
the 60s i think there's something for
everybody here so
dust it out
final thoughts
i'm excited i can see all the chaos that
can happen especially for people
toggling the gravity and you know
feeding you can actually feed your your
passengers food too like that's another
way to entertain them yes so
there's a lot you can do on the ship and
so i'm excited i can see the chaos
especially when you have like a group of
four people just playing and
you know just it's it's got a lot of
potential i'm excited
well guys thank you so much for being
here uh snowy and fabu fabio is great
having you we're excited to play um
it looks amazing
thank you yeah thanks
thank you both i can't wait to be able
to play this and jump in and just you
know run my own sort of intergalactic
flight crew uh i'm really i'm gonna be
the worst team member i'm just gonna
choose chaos the entire time
so
i have to keep an eye out for those
airlocks just in case
wow very cool well thank you so much um
now moving on we actually uh uh we do
have another exclusive trailer for you
all that we think you're gonna really
want uh you're gonna enjoy so here's a
look
at the artful escape oh my gosh
no
[Music]
yo i'm johnny galvatron and i'm a person
who works at beethoven and dinosaur
right now i'm going to be showing you a
game that we've been working on since
the fall of the ottoman empire in 1904
it's a game about a teenage guitar
prodigy called francis vendetti
francis is living in the shadow of his
uncle a dead folk superstar who many
consider to be the voice of a generation
attempting to escape the expectations of
his hometown and his own insecurities
francis embarks on a multi-dimensional
adventure to inspire a new stage persona
it's called the artful escape
it begins as many stories do at home
and francis's hometown is calypso
colorado
francis
you little bastard come to me my love
i think when you're beneath those lights
i might catch a glimpse of my old friend
you'll believe it's 1955.
anyway a bunch of nonsense occurs and
carl weathers floats majestically into
town
i'm supposed to be a serious folk
musician
oh baby we'll have you back in time for
breakfast
lena heady shows up to play a giant
floating asymmetrical space head
well if it isn't a fluffy little piece
of space dust
then it gets a bit weird
[Music]
we're going to drop you into the
heliotrons now for some musical mischief
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the game uses a cipher called the
musical key to interact and jam with the
multiverse you can use it to unlock
doors free jam communicate with the
impossible creatures and summon a part
of disco worms
[Music]
[Music]
we've only shown you a little of all the
nonsense that happens in the artful
escape like boss jams talk shows and
cosmic lungs but here's some character
customization set to a song written in
1988 by my musical partner josh abrahams
who doesn't know i stole it off his
computer
our september 9
peace
[Music]
megan you were kidding when you when you
saw that logo you freaked out well i
read the chat i read the chat and it
said artful escape i already knew it was
annapurna i'm i cannot this that game is
so incredible i've been following it
since it got announced i actually got to
uh speak with the dev the dude who was
talking and he is like he was in surfer
shorts he's so laid-back and so chill
and like how he was doing his vo that's
how he is in real life that game is
something i've been looking forward to
it's it feels like a mix of like night
in the woods and oxen free meets wander
like they're just so
it's just so beautiful right
i love that and
i personally like i love the art style
like this is kind of a game that again i
just know like i haven't played like
stuff like oxen free so like this kind
of has that kind of vibe but what i love
about this because i like my before i
got into gaming my previous career was
in radio so i like and i grew up kind of
like with the 60s 70s 80s and 90s kind
of like music i love the kind of like
classic rock style and like hearing the
guitar riffs and the guitar harmonies
and just the just the distortion and
like even the voice cast was kind of
cool like it just has this neat like uh
like look to it that i think in a way
only annapurna can be able to kind of
like like do in the like in this sort of
like epic kind of uh
in this really cool epic way uh i'm i'm
stoked
i'm so stoked annapurna is like my
favorite studio they just know how to uh
release like the best games the way they
curate games i already know i'm gonna
love it and like that title card comes
up and i'm like yeah i'm i'm
pre-ordering i'm saving it and this one
has been a long-awaited
uh one so it's so cool to see that new
gameplay the customization at the end um
oh man i'm so excited i'm sorry i'm
having a moment me too i mean i'm just
excited we've got to see some amazing
games today from the idea and xbox
that's gonna be coming soon we like we
saw stuff for like the the veil which
i'm personally loving i i love that like
that's there um we got to see just a ton
of like really uh like uh just
pathfinder paparazzi um we gotta like
find out
like stardew coming to like coming to
game pass
like it's just it's so it's so cool like
what are your thoughts of uh like what
were your favorite moments of this so
far
uh well i blacked out when i was talking
to eric during that stardew moment i got
real sweaty um so i think that was my
favorite moment as long as it was okay
do you think i did all right it was good
no you did great you did you did
fantastic yeah sarah bond here i was
trying to be super cool so you know i
don't know obviously artful escape is
like one of the games i've been looking
forward to the most um and so that
trailer reveal at the very end probably
takes the cake for me but there's so
many games i can't wait to play i have
like i have like a little notes list i'm
gonna go back and watch this stream and
just uh kind of like save
it as my on
i can't even i can't speak anymore steve
it's okay it's okay we're right there
with you i'm right there it's okay we
can breathe we can breathe it's like
we're good we're done uh thank you so
much for everyone tuning in um just to
let you know there's going to be some
upcoming twitch gaming shows before we
say goodbye we want to let you know that
chat that the gamescom 2021 xbox stream
is set to happen on tuesday august 24th
at 10 a.m pacific time hosted by
an amazing dude paris lily and kate
yeager i am so looking forward to that
shout outs to them they're amazing
amazing creators and i can't wait to be
able to see them host this dang thing
it's gonna be so great so make sure to
follow uh twitch gaming and xbox's
twitch channels for
that event also plus this thursday tune
in for a new episode of the weekly right
here on twitch gaming hosted by trisha
hershberger and actually i could be able
to say this for the first time this is
kind of cool and myself i will be the
co-host with trisha uh this thursday so
it should be a really really fun yeah
oh this is exciting it should be a
really fun show again that's this
thursday at 11 a.m pacific only on
twitch gaming
and special thanks to all of the devs
and the streamers who dropped by today
the lovely sarah bond from microsoft
eric barone from stardew valley fabio
rosa space lines from far out dave evans
the veil that was so cool talking to him
and seeing you guys just like go back
and forth i love that uh
and then um
uh carolina almeida and david jimenez
this has just been an action-packed show
and it's been so wonderful getting to
know you and co-hosting with you steve
you are just so lovely
ah thanks so much oh man so it was an
absolute pleasure pleasure to be able to
hang out with you today and just talk
about indies and xbox thank you for
being my uncle iro uh i i appreciate it
so much we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to i'm gonna i have so much to
learn and and this is just a little
little little bit into the indie world
and and uh i want to thank you for being
a guide um but for those of you like who
in the chat who may
uh want to be able to follow you and and
also be able to find out the uh the
indie guide or the uncle iro herself can
you tell us a little like where can we
be able to find you online yes of course
i i am an internet dinosaur i've been
around for the last like 14 years so you
can find me anywhere on social media at
strawberry17 but specifically on twitch
strawberry 17 plays usually stream
tuesdays thursdays and saturday stardew
gta a lot of uh indie games and pixel
art uh i would love to get to know some
of the people in chat so stop on by say
hello um but yeah that's me
steve what about you where can we find
you where are you at where are you
hanging well yeah much like you i'm also
like an old internet dinosaur i've been
around for for a long time but you can
be able to find me uh on twitter at
steve saylor that's s-a-y-l-o-r
uh you can also find me here on twitch
at blindgamersteve or on youtube
youtube.com
snowball i talk a lot about
accessibility and i do accessibility
reviews and i just also fun uh gaming
and i kind of like i also get to consult
with studios and i get to talk about
that experience and i just advocate for
accessibility industry because as xbox
likes to be able to say when everybody
plays we all win so that's uh true
yep i love that
you exist
yeah that's fantastic all right so that
is
thank you megan
no steve you stop it i'm thanking you
thank thank you and thanks for everyone
are watching a chat thank you for
everyone at microsoft for making today
possible
and uh we'll see you guys later what a
good show
bye chat
[Music]
you